For example, the Google News experience on the desktop
shows a lot of information, but the mobile experience
focuses on just the news stories. Pushing all of
the secondary information out of the way. You'll learn how
to write code that adapts to different screen sizes
and also how to make your code work offline.
You'll learn how pointer input works on touch screens
and how to unlock the camera GPS and accelerometers sensors
on mobile devices. Now technically speaking you don't need
a mobile device in order to take this course or
even to test out most of what you'll learn.
But you're missing a lot of the experience of mobile
web development, without a device. Preferably at least one
Android device. You can use Chrome's great mobile debugging tools.
Which we'll be using in this course. But, the
more devices you have, and the more variety, the better.